hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and I'm John Humphrey guys over on
patreon there's a guy named Andrew Hayes
Hayes has a movie review channel and
here's one of our top pledges on patreon
- guy he does project but he's got a lot
of enthusiasm and one of the reward
tiers that he has is any video he
requests that we do a topic on or a
reaction to we must effing a lot day we
are bound and do it today's is top 10
worst movies a deserve a remake from
watchmojo.com over let's check it out
camera might cut in the middle of it cuz
it only welcome to our picks for the top
10 worst movies and so on surrounding it
and
Lipsius Aragon presents a really bad
movie the first entry inheritance cycle
fantasy novel series was self-published
by the still teenaged author Christopher
Paolini
and his family back in 2002 are you
ready - terrible
it quickly gained an ardent fan base and
received the big-budget movie treatment
only a few years later to a balanced
sentiment of both excitement and
skepticism
[Music]
although the author himself approve of
the translation critics we're not so
forgiving with many accusing the film
story of being too derivative of the
Star Wars and the Lord of the Rings
franchises while also remarking
first-time directors step in Fangmeier
without here Stefan Fangmeier we're
hoping another stab at an adaptation
would be able to highlight what fans had
loved about it in the first place
literally the author liked it honey how
old was he actually wrote it was like 18
[Music]
with the DC EU they don't make a bunch
of films properly on the big screen yeah
she was
case in point this 2004 my bear is
pretty hot all accounts has to be one of
the worst comic book adaptations ever
over time Halle Berry stars as patients
Philips a new incarnation to heroin in
what is essentially another origin story
you've died use its a girlfriend
American Horror Story
[Applause]
[Music]
unfortunately crazy cat lady ripped
exaggerated performances and some of the
most cringe-worthy CGI imaginable he's
also went dr. strange he's crossed over
both universes and he's in cocoa nine
lives and means they have at least a few
more chances to revamp this feline femme
fatale number eight Alexander Harris
solace from Oliver Stone may have
already inundated the market with his
disappointing 2004 historical drama but
we say that there's still a demand out
here for the story of Alexander the
great to be told and told well a king is
a born Alexander I don't watch this
movie looks like so entertaining free
yeah sure Colin Farrell may not have
completely convinced in the title role
but stones film wasn't entirely without
merit telling an epic tale during an era
when films like gladiator and Troy were
still fresh in people's minds yeah
they all came to the end of the time and
in the end when it's over all that
matters is what you've done maybe
instead of yet another rieta dove the
Oliver Stone version though some other
up-and-coming director could add a fresh
spin to the story denis villeneuve oh
yeah it was a cool first trail
particularly liked by critics in recent
years however interest in this cinematic
franchise as a cool shot decline it's
over now they had like three final
chapters what could kickstart Resident
Evil once again we say a remake with
practical effects makeup and monsters
[Laughter]
directors this could be just the boost
Resident Evil needs to once again rise
to the occasion
[Music]
getting rid of Alice and focusing on
characters from the videogames may also
help ya actually base this off the
videogame would probably do pretty well
oh god if I was in this movie Michael
Bay drew critical ire when he decided to
adapt the 1941 Japanese attack on Pearl
Harbor into a romantic dramatization
starring Ben Affleck Kate Beckinsale and
Josh Hartnett Titanic man many cried
foul at the film's historical
inaccuracies and love triangle subplot
significant financial rewards at the box
office however its crochet and we think
the story could still be done justice
it's placed in the hands of someone
capable of balancing both action and
storytelling in the proper ratio based
on the celebrated comic-book series this
was another case of Hollywood not
properly following the source material I
think is very strong it's pretty bad
rates for a big budget action film
following Alan Moore and Kevin O'Neill's
tale of fantastic fictional characters
from history dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
it's Russell Crowe the like still balked
at the League of Extraordinary Gentlemen
Tom Sawyer plans for a franchise quickly
fizzled out
2015 first unearthed rumors of a reboot
however so the time may yet still come
for Alan Quartermaine dr. Jekyll Tom
Sawyer and Captain Nemo to rebuild their
league on a big or small yes fun what
they all need it was individual films
don't try to make this movie a cult
following regardless of critical or
commercial distance oh those are so cool
brothers is one of those films
[Music]
yeah all right this very loose
adaptation of the classic Nintendo game
first hit theaters in 1993 our costumes
flashy action sequences and wacky
performances abound in Super Mario
Brothers
yeah it's tenuous link to the video game
series didn't win it many favors with
fans at the time although we're not sure
anything they read tear it into the
merging Super Mario Brothers we'd love
to see some inventive filmmaker out
there try his hand at remaking this one
number 3 The Last Airbender camera cut
fans have been known to get up in arms
what a film adaptation misses the mark
damn night nothing touches the recently
negative reaction to M night Shyamalan
stake on the animated series but he made
split now so it's cool not only did fans
react negatively to the casting of
Caucasian actors in what should have
been a Jindal's but the Avatar community
and others also commented on the bridge
team without white director and special
effects all of which were almost
universally paying I will stop them even
if you've never watched the show it's
clear by this point that avatar fans
deserve a proper big-screen adventure
with their heroes I don't think that's a
good idea
number two spawn yes they are doing it
he has a little old by the late 90s
didn't exactly foster the same comic
friendly cinema climate we enjoy today
Michael Jai White stars as creator Todd
McFarlane's betrayed military man who
sells his soul to the devil in order to
return to the woman he loves only to
find out that she has remarried his best
friend in the five years since his death
icicle effect we think that a character
with such a tragic backstory needs to
make a serious comeback not to mention
the fact that spawn himself is
practically the definition of a badass
as he fights demons
that's like how the movie went wrong
there's a shadow like this so - why does
a raptor impression on your first day of
school this is not remake Doug Lyman's
jumper without total fell I'm gonna
explain it but I do it really oh hey
that's based on a book sphere yeah it's
based on Michael Crichton book
[Music]
number one the Golden Compass I would
have been resident evil' Harry Potter
and the Lord of the Rings franchises the
Golden Compass has been described as one
of the most disappointing adaptations
ever but the ruling power fearing any
truth of their own destroys these
devices or infer made the very mention
of dust shine away from Philip Pullman's
source material it was criticized for
blunting the anti-catholic sentiment
within the film while religious
organizations complained about how said
themes stemmed from the source material
move to me that you are a demon how did
I become however with several years
having gone by since its release perhaps
it'll soon be the right time to
re-evaluate once again now yeah without
enter to bring Pullman's tale to life
what's that that dude she's so hot
fingers crossed that the BBC can do His
Dark Materials justice on the small
screen yes do you agree with our list
which bad movies do you think deserve
some redemption give me an answer so I
can go home oh wow provoking top 10 list
every day
be sure to subscribe to watchmojo.com
[Music]
thanks WatchMojo good list if I were to
contribute one at x-men origins
Wolverine oh I feel like that would be
great for rebooting and reintroducing
Wolverine everyone knows how terrible
that movie went down and if you want to
get a new over reign redo the origin two
birds one stone with that two birds one
stone
reintroduction redo a good origin tale
because we still haven't gotten a good
origin tale of Wolverine and you build
up so much mystery and passes a guy then
it's a bummer when you watch that
freaking film that is a good idea G so I
would say that one also
top 11 Passion of the Christ yeah that
needs to go down better make it twice as
fast go back on slo-mo you make it four
kids yeah it still focuses on the last
12 hours of Christ's life but you make
it but you know G he cracks jokes now
yeah and Mel Gibson he's in daddy's home
now so he's familiar with family films
yeah he remakes it makes it a family you
know Aragon Aragon I was part of a focus
group way before YouTube for this one
movie all right
where they pay me $75 to be in a room
with a bunch of other know-it-all
wannabe filmmakers from High School
where the target market will have an
opinion and they showed us three
trailers and then we receive our
feedback on it they went with the one I
didn't like oh why did you get to here
why why they didn't take the trailer I
don't know it didn't matter to me it
move all three trailers look pretty
shitty I were the one that I thought was
liable here let me explain you and now
who's the trailer expert ha ha ha all
you take faces I don't even remember
take that $75 there's 75 bucks yeah
that's good money for I was arrested on
the same day he actually was something
else
Catwoman's gonna happen yeah I mean at
this point I think DC should just
greenlight a bunch of movies bunch more
they've already greenlit like a bunch
have no release dates yeah so why
Catwoman to the mix guys we don't need
to see her in a Batman movie we don't we
don't we want to see
solo Catwoman movie with a Batman Cammy
yeah yeah no I can see that maybe work
can't woman's got her got her thing
camel was a terrible movie this yeah
that is a bad movie as a wacky movie you
know Benjamin Bratt I remember very few
things about this movie Bratz a cop yeah
and at one point he suspects early on
that she might be the thief and then
especially he notices their handwriting
is very similar and then a lot adds up
and then he takes it to a pen expert or
whatever oh yeah and then they're like
well this version is an insecure woman
this version is a confident woman
there's clearly two different human
beings alright basketball the Resident
Evil Resident Evil seems like this I
know just just just borrow anything from
the game what would be so cool to me
it's a survival solo survive that's like
yeah use the first game it's just two
people and then you can choose right you
choose whichever one you wanna play us
or yeah you have like a team but you
only run into those dudes like once a
night like you'll see marry and he'll
give you a lockpick it's a haunted
mansion and [ __ ] and there's more to it
and what I thought would be so cool to
do that now one rezian movie is done is
shoot and edit it the way how you play
the game how you play worse this one
should like it how you walking to the
next shot all the time you walk into the
next frame how sweet with epi well and
like that's the thing is I feel like
there there are lessons that can be
learned from Silent Hill and those
lessons are like take the aesthetics see
ya and Resident Evil is a very visual
game and like the only things they used
I felt like for this movie were the
liquor and an umbrella and then they
like started going hog-wild with the
references later on yeah like start a
universe that actually feels like
Resident Evil and that's not hard to do
at all you know Pearl Harbor though yes
for all I don't know if remake Pearl
Harbor I think they should remake this
specific version of Pearl Harbor
I feel like this director always does
the same style and I can't get kind of
annoying that he all his movies or shot
the samp but he tends to do it great
when he does its paul greengrass man i
think paul greengrass to make a great
Pearl Harbor movie I think that could be
like his epic
okay the one that's a little maybe where
he breaks away a little bit from being
so on the ground yeah how dumb Kirk is
like Nolan's World War two movie I feel
like Paul Greengrass could make his
Pearl Harbor movie where you cut around
to multiple different stories mm-hmm or
he would just tell it at one specific
location what a three different time
period League of Extraordinary Gentlemen
I think is a really fun movie I mean
it's it's awful it is awful but there's
just some like cool cheesy stuff to be
had I mean you're watching The Invisible
Man dr. Jekyll and mr. this is the dark
universe it has a balun more style but
not faithful at all with Captain Nemo -
and Captain Nemo man and I'm Tom so an
Artemis quarter is John Connery I'm
waiting to be impressed I'm waiting to
be impressed I'm waiting to be impressed
sorry how does it stack up - van Helsing
I think it's better than van Helsing van
Helsing should use a ream man could use
like that the way they approach Downey
would think was a terrible idea to do
come out I hate when they take horror
genres amazing action movies I just
can't stand that it gets me so annoyed
yeah I can do I can do horror adventure
but not like straight-up horror action
yeah like horror action is hard to do
that's the League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen is even though they're not all
horror based I don't think you can do
Mario no I think they're talking about
making an animated mark yeah oh that
would be cool I mean weed wants to the
video the Nintendo Cinematic Universe us
pitching our idea and see I think a
Super Mario animated movie would be
sweet I think I could totally get on
board with that I even go on board with
motion capture Peter Dinklage plays all
the roles what did you do then as you
know you set up a cool cheeky Nintendo
formula that everyone thinks is amazing
like three movies in when you're doing
the you know like Luigi movie people
like you gotta update the style yeah you
know they could be the next leg oh that
would be sweet man I think a Super Mario
mood would work The Last Airbender I
think this movie is so underrated
oh yeah this to me was Shyamalan when he
when he really hit his stride really
cared
we saw him warming
lady in the water right yeah yeah and
then the happening you're like I think
this guy's got some getting cruising
altitude Manny Z's about to reach it but
when we hear the latch there bender I
was like this guy's here to stay this
guy's gonna be around a while and then I
see like some responses I'm like what is
up with audiences this is this is really
exactly the show
man's show I remember I had to sit
through like horrible [ __ ] from this guy
the sixth sense
oh I'm breakable I'm like oh my god
another one I a comic look watchable
signs here's a sign don't watch it it's
not let's just leave it at this
I think the Golden Compass they gotta
wait missus to wait a little while when
they come out 2007 yeah yeah we a little
while that's like a 20 to 30 year wait
yeah I'm a character you know you gotta
weigh like 20 to 30 years yeah every
some amalgamation of decades it seems
like the the film marketplace yearns for
a good epic fantasy yeah at that time
you know if the Golden Compass is such
is a beloved classic you know story like
that
yeah wait because you don't want to
become just one in a drove yeah it's
kind of for about Chronicles of Narnia
like you guys got away so yeah I think I
feel like that was kind of made at the
wrong time like we got to this
generation we got Lord of the Rings at
Harry Potter those were two like
sprawling epic things and fast and
furious and fast all tails I feel like
even Narnia I just saw the first one
again last night which is the second
book you like they're always making
those movies out of order and and yeah I
feel like that's one that could use its
time I agree with statements hey Andrew
Hayes thanks for recommending this video
this is really fun
watchmojo.com great video great video
guys subscribe to the real rejects
please do yourself a favor and click
that note if the case shown Abed you can
check out our patreon become a patron
eject today it's a lot a lot of fun over
there did the math earlier have over 260
exclusive posts
they're two six zeros I'm gonna give you
a hint though 259 of them are only
pictures
haha all the same picture that's funny
working on it people